if you've been following spacex's latest
mars prototype rocket
sn9 you may have very well gotten
frustrated seeing scrub
after scrub after scrub now
starship is a prototype rocket but
launch clubs are a dime a dozen within
the rocket industry
given that rocket explosions are super
expensive and dangerous
it's no wonder why launch postponements
are so common
space organizations only want to launch
under the best circumstances possible
long term though in order to
successfully establish rapid
point-to-point travel
and a gateway to mars launch reliability
is essential
so will rockets ever become that
[Music]
reliable
well to answer this let's take a look at
why rockets get scrubbed in the first
place
starting with of course weather weather
is by far the most common reason rocket
launches get delayed
and this caution was really sparked by
the challenger disaster
the challenger disaster is thought to
have occurred due to cold weather
conditions
which led to a buildup of ice on the
rocket's o-rings
as a result nasa does not allow any
rocket launches to take place today
if the temperature is below 48 degrees
fahrenheit
aside from warm temperatures nasa and
the faa
have a plethora of lightning-related
restrictions rocket launchers have to be
extremely careful about lightning
as rockets can trigger lightning at
lower electrical fields
as they pass through clouds nasa claims
that a rocket getting struck by
lightning can cause short-circuiting of
key electronic systems
like the navigation system and the
self-destruct system
if this self-destruct system were to
fail the rocket could crash into a
populated area
after getting struck by lightning but
wait a minute
don't airplanes get struck by lightning
all the time and come out flawless
if airplanes can handle it shouldn't a
top top-of-the-line rocket be able to
handle a lightning strike
well the answer is yes rockets can
handle lightning strikes
and it has even occurred in the past way
back in 1969
apollo 12 would be struck by lightning
twice on the way up
the lightning strikes would generate a
flash of fear as neither the astronauts
or mission control knew exactly what
happened
all they saw were a flurry of different
warnings
fortunately though the lightning strikes
caused a bunch of alerts to go off
no major systems were really harmed and
the mission would be completed
successfully
18 years later though an atlas and tar
rocket wouldn't be as lucky
in 1987 an atlas centaur rocket would
also be hit by lightning
and this would cause the loss of the
rocket and the payload
it's a good thing that there was no crew
on board
anyways this instant would lead to the
creation of the lightning advisory panel
today these guys monitor cloud thickness
reflectivity
and temperatures to predict the chance
of a lightning strike and determine if a
rocket launch
is safe as you can see rockets are
designed to withstand lightning strikes
however lightning has caused a disaster
in the past
so the consensus has become better safe
than sorry
moving on we have rain snow and hill
again planes generally don't have issues
when it comes to these forces
here's the thing though planes and
rockets move in different directions
the majority of a plane's velocity is in
the x direction
while the majority of a rocket's
velocity is in the y direction
this does decrease throughout the flight
as rockets don't go straight up into the
air
but their angle of ascent is no doubt
much steeper than a regular airplane
moreover rockets would be traveling at
thousands of miles per hour when they
pass through a hypothetical rain
or snowstorm meanwhile airplanes are
only traveling
at hundreds of miles per hour as you
would guess colliding into millions of
water droplets or snow pellets at
supersonic speeds
is not the best of ideas the real threat
though
is not actually in the santa face the
main concern
is that large snow pellets or hail may
damage the heat shield
and this would cause serious
complications during re-entry
as we saw with colombia anyways moving
on to the last major weather concern
on earth we have wind for a rocket
launch to potentially take place
winds from the northeast can be no
faster than 21 miles per hour
and winds from other directions can be
no faster than 39 miles per hour
you see rockets may have several or even
dozens of engines
but they all point in one direction
downwards
as a result the engines have little
flexibility in actually changing the
trajectory of the launch
generally they can gimble a little bit
which allows for minor corrections in
the flight path
but this can't account for any major
deviations despite the strength of the
engines
on the topic of weather we also have to
be careful of space weather
considering that rockets travel out of
their earth's atmosphere
space organizations not only have to be
careful of weather conditions on the
earth
but also space weather the main obstacle
when it comes to inclement space weather
is space radiation sometimes an
abnormally high amount of high energy
protons will gather
around earth's atmosphere this can be
caused by solar flares and other violent
solar activity
and though it seems like just protons
this high density of protons can lead to
serious radiation concerns
excess radiation can also cause the heat
shield to degrade faster than expected
which may jeopardize re-entry so that's
the main weather concerns
within the earth and outside the earth
more substantial weather conditions like
hurricanes
tornadoes and floods will also cause
grubs
but that's a no brainer the russians
have actually worked through many of the
more minor weather conditions
such as cold weather the thing is
russian weather
is not nearly as nice as weather in
florida or boca chica texas
as a result handling inclement weather
has been one of their primary goals from
the very beginning
after all you can't call off a nuclear
war just because it's under 45 degrees
fahrenheit
with that being said weather is not too
difficult of hurdle to overcome
but then why are spacex rockets still
being scrubbed all the time
well the answer is cost either you can
design a super robust rocket
capable of handling a variety of weather
challenges that's expensive to launch
or you can design a much cheaper rocket
that's more sensitive to weather
conditions
considering that spacex is straight up
welding together stainless steel rings
for their upcoming starship rocket
they have clearly favored the second
option at this point in time
the cost of launching rockets has proven
to be a much more serious issue
when compared with developing a rocket
that can handle more weather conditions
as a result spacex as well as most space
agencies have placed their focus
primarily on reducing cost
however once this goal has been achieved
it shouldn't be that technically
challenging to make the rockets more
robust
though it may prove to be a financial
challenge it should be noted that
weather
isn't the only reason that rocket
launches are scrubbed though another
major hurdle responsible for dozens of
last-minute scrubs
is mechanical difficulties as rocket
technology has advanced
so has the complexity of its various
systems you know
self-tanning boosters didn't just happen
by themselves
concurrently space organizations have
also become much more knowledgeable
about the various minor errors that can
lead to massive catastrophes
through years of trial and error for
instance
in 2015 a falcon 9 rocket would
disintegrate
shortly after liftoff due to a failed
steel strut
similarly in 2016 a falcon 9 would
explode
on the test stand while being fueled up
due to an adverse reaction between
oxygen
and the carbon fiber composites within
the fuel tank
each time a disaster takes place the
given organization
and other space organizations all have
dozens of new sensors
and systems in order to prevent the same
error from occurring
in the future thus as we continue to
move forward
more and more sensors and systems have
to give the green light
before a launch can take place
considering the raw number of sensors
it's not surprising that one of them
will give a false or real alert
here and there causing delays to the
launch
this is also a very easy issue to fix
long term
as rocket technology continues to become
more stable and space organizations
slowly get better at discerning between
false alarms and real threats
we should see fewer and fewer delays due
to mechanical difficulties
and that brings us into the final reason
that rocket launches are scrubbed
which is danger to people down below
sometimes
rocket launches aren't scrubbed due to
inclement weather or mechanical issues
rather they're delayed because of random
people on the surface of the earth
for instance one time a nasa iss
resupply mission was scrubbed
because of a random passenger sailboat
that came within 40 miles of the launch
site
the problem was that if the rocket
exploded in the sky
fragments of the rocket may fall onto
sailboats and harmed civilians
as you know though planes cross above
our heads all the time
so this issue is also just more of a
precaution
as opposed to a serious obstacle at the
end of the day
rocket launches are scrubbed all the
time but
fortunately these issues aren't too
terribly difficult to fix
the three main reasons launches are
scrubbed are inclement weather
mechanical difficulties and potential
harm to civilians
the main detriment in overcoming these
obstacles is simply a lack of focus in
this area
right now this isn't a bad thing though
it simply makes more sense to focus on
making rockets fully reusable
and significantly cheaper before giving
them more flexible launch capabilities
once starship proves the viability of
cheap fully reusable rocketry
it won't take long for spacex and other
space organizations to adapt their
rockets to withstand more weather
conditions
and reduce technical difficulties do you
guys agree
comment that down below also drop a like
if you guys are excited for starship to
finally make space travel
a much more affordable endeavor and of
course consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then
i'm hari i'll see you guys on the next
[Music]
one
you